hello everyone and welcome to some
drama from the chess world not a lot but
a reasonable amount we are in the finals
of the
first ever fide online chess olympiad
and
it's a very nice game from the second
match between india
uh and russia vidit versus nepo and it's
quite the game and we're going to talk
about what happened
in the entire match after after we check
out the game so without further ado
let's check it out the vidit with the
white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6
but
first sorry about that uh knight to f6
and the c4 we have g6 and the knight the
c3
going for for the groomfield so the
grunfeld is on the board we have d5
captures captures and e4 uh going for
the main line with captures captures and
now bishop to g7 preparing c5 to strike
in the center
we have bishop to e3 and c5 now so this
is all
uh very standard stuff we have queen d2
and now queen to a5 putting more
pressure
on white's center we have knight to f3
uh developing while defending and here
nepal just castles with rook to c1 now
adding another defender to the c3 pawn
preparing d5
and here bishop to g4 by uh nepo saying
that okay if you go d5 i might be
interested in capturing your knight and
messing up your pawn structure
uh but this is exactly what the vidid
goes for he pushes d5 and now allows
this uh
ruining of with its pawn structure on
the king side and this is
in fact the the most often played move
here but nepo
very rarely plays what is often and goes
for b5
and now what's happening here he's
giving up the c5 pawn but what
uh what does he he get by this uh well
uh vidiq goes for it bishop captures on
c5
now also putting pressure on e7 but now
comes rook to c8 so what
is uh what is nepal's idea uh well uh if
the bishop moves there will be a triple
attack on the c5 pawn so it obviously
has something to do with that
so bishop to d4 or bishop to b4 is an
idea here if
it goes for bishop to b4 attacks napo's
queen
and the queen back to c7 now clearing
the path for the 48 pawn to start
marching forward
uh we have knight to d4 here veda
doesn't allow the ruining of the pawn
structure
and now nepo continues with his pushing
of the pawns with
a5 we have bishop back to a3 and now b4
everything completely forced and this is
still not a new game this was
all of this was played before uh in last
year's uh uh grand swiss
fiat grand swiss uh between uh um uh
andres pence and dwayne jones but we're
going to mention that when we
get to the to the fork uh so here we
have bishop to b2
uh if you go for the c captures on b and
open up an attack on the queen as the
bishop does defend the rook here you get
queen e5 now with a double attack on the
knight
and even after the trade captures
captures with check
queen to c2 uh uh just uh
getting rid of the defense of the knight
by attacking the bishop on c8 for
example bishop d7 and now bishop to b2
it is playable but now he captures on b4
and black can be
can be very happy with what's happening
here so instead after b4 we have just
bishop back to b2 by vidit and then now
comes queen to b6 by nepo
and even though uh vidid is still up
upon you kind of feel that
nipple really got got enough for the
sacrificed pawn
uh and here this is where the game takes
a different turn in the
uh grand swiss last year asipanko went
c4 here
and he won a game against gawain jones
but here instead we have bishop to be
five by viret and it is as of move 17
that we have a completely new game which
is also a very interesting move because
it kind of seems like it blunders a
piece
why not just capture the defender of the
bishop and then eliminate the bishop
so it's very it's a very interesting
idea i feel free to pause the video here
and figure out is it okay to grab
the the knight and the bishop while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who decided that
it's okay to go for it
it's most definitely not and for those
who
just want to enjoy the show the reason
why it's not uh is because if you go for
it bishop captures queen captures and
the now
uh queen captures here well there's the
problem of this queen bishop battery
just c4 and black either loses a queen
or gets
checkmated and there's there's nothing
more to be done here
so that's why it's not okay to go for
the piece of it it is on top of all the
all the tactics
with bishop to b5 so first e5 by nipple
he tries to get rid of the defender of
the bishop this way and also closes up
this diagonal but now uh
d captures an e6 alpha song we have
bishop captures an e6 and now a trade
captures captures and
now c4 adding a defender to the bishop
and offering a trade of
dark square bishops which nipple goes
for with bishop captures queen captures
in the now
finally knight to c6 and while you could
castle now but it says there's there's
no rush let's go after nipples
real weakness that is the e6 pawn so
queen to f6 is going after the pawn
and now knight to d4 defending it with
the knight and the queen
but allowing avid to this very nice
bishop to d7 idea
now with a double attack on the rook and
on the pawn
uh here we have rook to f8 attacking
with its queen and queen to e5 and here
we reach the position from the thumbnail
and the nipple goes for his rook
captures on f2 idea b3
is one possibility trying to create a
pass pawn
uh or or or just a force uh force open
some lines
uh but nepo's idea also is a very nice
one he plays the rook captures on f3 and
what he wants here
is to get a vidic king uh in front of
the queen to
well be able to do some very nasty
discoveries and uh
although it looks very ugly it's like in
that game we've shown where
uh kasparov played against carlson we're
calls and had to play that king captures
on h2 it's same here
vidit has to play king captures on f2
and
go in front of some nasty discoveries
but there aren't all that many of them
for example if you go knight c6 it seems
like you can win the queen
but not really sorry about that arrow c5
and there's just not all that much to do
for example knight captures captures
here
you're to capture the bishop as well but
now b7 just wins the game
easy for black for example rook b8
you're going to go here with check
king f7 you're going to go rook to c7
and once you atta
you know on pin you're going to go rook
to d1
and now there's not much you can do
about avoiding the knight
uh if you move the knight let's say
knight to f6 you're just going to get
a nice rook the c8 to check and if you
try something like let's say
knight knights the b6 still doesn't help
rook the d6 is coming
and you're either losing the knight or
rook the c8 check is coming
so uh you can't uh very well go for this
so instead after this king captures on
f2
uh instead we have rook to f8 check uh
and here witted really has to decide
what to do here does he go back
or does he go uh up the board now it's a
very
uh counterintuitive to march your king
up the board but king the g3 is actually
very interesting here but it
uh it's so ugly to play that uh well
not not a lot of people would play this
especially in a rapid game where you
have uh
very little time on the clock uh but if
king g3 then
92 check forces the king further up the
board king h4
queen to d8 check but now you can defend
with queen to g5
and here you have to give up the bishop
back and then continue the game rook c
to f1
uh trade off the rooks and then enjoy as
you're still up the exchange although
your king is on a very
very bad square however you should be
able to push for advantage here but it's
it's extremely hard like i said
especially in a rapid game like
if black just gets a few moves and he
already has a pass pawn
and it could get very dangerous but the
root uh
vitid chose he played queen king to e3
offering even more nasty discoveries now
there's a double check possible with
knight to f5 also a double check
possible with knight
to c2 check as it would be a check from
both the knight and
the queen uh uh nipple goes for knights
to f5 with check
and now again what do you play here uh
whatever you play queen to e3
is coming next because both the knight
and the queen guard that square now so
king d3
queen to e3 with check king the c2
and now knight to d4 with check we have
king to b1
and now queen to d3 with check king to
a1
uh and here nepo uh of course made a
very nice rook lift rook to f2 because
if you try something like knights to see
to check white would be more than happy
to give you uh
the rook it's not a problem because
after bishop captures on e6
uh black is completely lost here you can
go captures captures bring another rook
into the game
but white is up for rook and black is
getting checkmated very very quickly for
example king g8 we're gonna go queen e8
to check here
and this is mate so after king to a1 we
have looked at f2 by nipple
now maybe with some ideas of rook
captures here followed by queen here
check check maybe not coming to b3 a lot
of things possible but
he still has to do something as bishop
captures an e6 is coming so this is
exactly what avid it does bishop
captures an e6
and now not capturing here uh the
the knight because if if knight captures
then rook h to d1
first getting the rook into the game and
now you're just uh
you're just completely lost once queen
captures comes and the other rook comes
into the game
uh that's uh there's not much you can do
here and
this doesn't help you like you could go
for rook captures on a2
and hope to get some sort of a perpetual
here but after king to b1
uh queen b3 now you can finally block
with queen to b2
and there is not much you can do now
you're just going to lose this game
so after bishop captures an e6 nipple
goes king to f8 now the rook on f2
prevents the rook from checking the king
along the f file uh and now queen d6
check by bit it king g7
queen the e7 check and now the problem
is nepo cannot go for king to h6 because
if king h6 queen h4 check picks up the
rook on f2 so nepal forced back with
king to h8 and
now again queen to d8 with check and
here
uh we do have a repetition king g7 queen
e7 czech king a chet queen d8 to check
king g7 and queen to e7
check and it was in this position on 37
uh that
vid it and nepo agreed to a draw and
while this game ended in a draw although
it was extremely wild
a lot of things have happened in both of
the matches and now we're gonna
show a little bit of what happened so
these are the standings of both matches
as you can see uh the one below is the
first match as you can see all the six
games ended in the draw so artemis hare
krishna
and of course we've seen the game nepal
versus vedic so all six games ended in
draw
and you have the first one uh where
uh you can see that not all games ended
in a draw but the problem is
uh that aside from the three games that
were drawn uh schwallowa
[Music]
defeated hampi canero the problem is um
both nikhil serena and divya deshmook
disconnected from their uh games and uh
well they lost on time and the hampi
canary also had a lot of
connection issues and even though she
was able to reconnect
later on uh she lost a lot of time and
you know just uh
uh her position deteriorated and
alexander goriaccio
won the game so it's hard to say no it's
hard to say if
the same thing wouldn't happen even
without disconnect but the problem is
uh india and russia were
both proclaimed winners of the 2020 fide
online olympiad by uh
uh by arkady vorkovich which is very odd
as uh
well such such a thing never never
happened in well
i i don't think in any sport uh because
so far when
one of the one of the players
disconnected i mean you disconnect you
lose but here
uh more than one player disconnected and
the vorkovich's decision was that
uh we're not gonna award russia the the
win we're
actually going to just make both teams
the winner
so it is a it is an odd decision we
still haven't had an official statement
from march
which feed the president and i will keep
you informed whenever we hear something
uh but here we have some uh well here we
have some tweets
just to check that out so you can see uh
levan arun of armenia
is very very dissatisfied with this he
says i guess like uh always
some of us are less disconnected than
others
i mean a point being that um uh india
reached the semi-finals by defeating
armenia and the uh uh and martyrossian
they also disconnected in his game
uh and well uh it was just uh he
disconnected so he lost and india
went to the to the semi-finals and here
now that uh three of the indian players
got disconnected
uh arkady dwarkovich said that uh
well uh we're not gonna we're not just
gonna award russia the win we're gonna
make both
india and the russia joint winners and
uh
yeah yanni pomnishi here tweeted that us
it's a smarter decision to please
indian chess community meanwhile
forgetting about other fans and players
a selective nobleness saying that uh
india has so many so many fans
in the chess world that it would be well
it would be foolish of
feed the president to you know just uh
say okay you lost due to this
disconnect issues uh and here you can
see that anand says
we are the champions congratulations
russia which can be
which can definitely be misinterpreted
as uh well they they are
joint joint winners it's not that india
are the champions and that
russia is like in second place uh but uh
pretty much everyone is tweeting it like
that for example here is a
tweet from the indian prime minister uh
narendra modi
he says congratulations to our chess
players for winning the fide online
chess olympiad
their hard work and dedication are
admirable their success will surely
motivate other chess players
and he would like to congratulate the
russian team as well
uh so while it is hard to figure out
who's congratulating who and what
actually happened
uh the the official well statement for
the moment is i don't think for the
moment i think it actually is that
they they both won gold so they are both
winners of the first ever feed
online olympiad and uh well it i
i guess like it's uh it's a reasonable
decision because uh you can't
just i mean what what are your auto
options your other option is to
either make russia the winner or to you
know say okay the both matches are a
draw
let's force a random armageddon on one
of the boards and play armageddon
but that's like also weird because if uh
well
uh two uh three of the uh indian players
had problems with
their connection uh if uh if uh
dork which for example proclaimed that
both the matches were a draw
and then rush uh lost the match in
armageddon then of course
the the the russian fans and the russian
community would be very angry so it is a
tricky tricky very tricky situation but
uh it's not that odd i mean we've had a
lot of problems
uh since this whole situation in the
world happened and
since the chess you know turned
completely online and we'll see
more problems like like these and it's
uh
it's hard to say will we respect the the
decision that
if a player disconnects then that's a
loss or will
uh sometimes you know people have to
step in and do something like this uh so
it's uh
definitely uh a bold decision by feeder
president takadi dworkovic so i'm
interested what
what's your opinion in this whole matter
was it was
was it a good decision was a bad
decision how would you handle the
situation
uh and and so on uh but yeah uh
congratulations to both india and russia
on winning defeated online uh 2020
olympiad
uh that's the game and and the the match
behind and
the story behind the match i do hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank
eric novak corey oliver david kimura
agita chechter and
manfred christ for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the good stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day